hello everyone and welcome to a rest day
from the wheelchairs championship match
we have no games today uh between the
Army publisher and England so I decided
uh to sort of make a mini Saga uh two
Bobby Fischer games as we already had
the big Bobby Fisher Saga if some of you
haven't seen it to do check it out on my
channel uh I'll even put a link to it in
the description below it's uh really uh
one of the nicest things you can see uh
online and uh this game uh is really
weird uh Bobby Fischer basically gets
destroyed in some 18 moves and when I
say destroyed I I'm not over
exaggerating or anything here uh he's
facing former world champion Max Irvin
who is okay at the time this game was
played he was already some 56 years old
uh and Fisher was 14 years old that in
this game even though there are a lot of
titles you will find online that say
Okay 13 year old Bobby Fisher uh you
know played this game uh and uh you know
they aren't wrong by a lot but they are
wrong because this uh game was played on
March 9 which is in fact Bobby Fischer's
birthday so that's why he was 14 already
during this game so here he faces a
former world champion Max do that in a
two-game match uh this is the first game
on the of the match and you guys that
will really love that one uh but the
second game I'm including in this Saga
will not be the second game of this
match it will actually be a game two of
them will play three years after this
game uh in the Leipzig chess Olympiad
but we're gonna yeah we're gonna get to
that so here uh it has the white pieces
and he opens with Pawn to D4 and Bobby
replies with Knight to F6 as he
uh usually did we have C for E6 Knight
to C3 and now Pawn to D5 Fischer goes
for the Queen's Gambit declined uh we
have C captures e captures and now
Bishop to G5 so very solid opening this
is the standard uh Bishop to G5 line and
now Bishop to G4 Bishop to B4 Bishop to
E7 is uh by far the the more common move
nowadays but okay Bishop to B4 also very
much playable Ponte E3 and now H6
challenging the the bishop here uh and
well nowadays you'd probably see a nice
Queen captures an F6 so let's say queen
captures and then Queen to B3 here we
have Bishop back to H4 also very much
playable and now up on the C5 Fisher
goes for a very principal decision going
after with a strong Center here uh with
Bishop to D3 and now Knight to C6 just
continuing development and Fisher plays
Knight to E2 and this is a position that
you would uh
uh very easily see even in modern chess
for example it was uh reached in the
world Blitz championship of 2015 between
Krishna and sasikiran and the Aryan
Tarin where Atari continued with C4 and
he lost that game but here Fisher plays
a c cappers on D4 which is in fact the
top move recommended by the engine uh we
have e-captor sund4 and now we have
Castles by both players so castles
castles and Bishop to E6 by Fisher with
Bishop to C2 the ship to C2 is the move
you don't expect from a former world
champion it's a
uh it's a move you might expect in a
bullet game because the idea is
basically Queen to D3 uh going after
Checkmate on H7 of course once we
eliminated this Knight but it is again
the strongest move recommended by the
engine okay you could maybe prepare it
maybe some H3 Rook to C1 then Bishop to
C2 but Bishop to C2 definitely a great
move with Bishop back the seven by
Fisher and now Knights the F4 there are
some games that reach this possession
but after Knight to F4 it is now as of
move 13 that this position has never
been reached again uh and Fisher goes
Queen to B6 and this is sort of where
things start to get uh really scary for
Fisher Queen to D7 was a lot safer
choice because now after Queen to B6 uh
everything is forced and look at this
bishop captures on F6 by Max uh Bishop
captures and F6 and now Queen to D3
Checkmate is being threatened and now
Fisher doesn't play G6 as one might
expect he plays Rook F to d8 he invites
Queen to H7 check but if the other goes
for this let's say queen queen goes H7
checking to f8 he still needs a move
because King can come to E7 later but
okay you can prepare Rook at one and now
you threatened
eliminate this bishop on E6 but instead
Max starts with Rook 8 to E1 he says I
have time for Queen to H7 and if you
play G6 that's not gonna be very good
for you because indeed uh if Fisher goes
Pawn to G6 here then you can trade
Knight captures on E6 and you're just
down a piece you can't capture back if
you capture back then Queen captures and
G6 Bishop G7 Queen captures an E6 with
check and you're just getting destroyed
here there's no no coming back from this
uh so instead after this uh uh Rook 881
move Fisher just played Knight the B4 he
attacks the queen here and the bishop on
C2 and now the question is how do you
continue uh from here uh obviously Queen
to H7 check is the must so this is
exactly what Max plays Queen to H7 check
King to f8 and now he plays a move that
one would not expect he plays just spawn
to A3 he says take the bishop on C2 uh I
don't mind but he doesn't really care if
Fisher takes the bishop because the
point of A3 is simply well I don't want
tell you the point because I might ruin
the post of the video moment but here
Fisher captures the bishop it doesn't
matter what Fisher plays here it's game
over so Fisher captures the bishop on C2
and now feel free to pause the video and
win the game from uh Max while I give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on sporting this
absolute brilliancy and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
Knight C Captain D5 this is what Max
played and Fisher could have easily
resigned here because now if the bishop
moves obviously this is checkmated The
Rook Now controls the E file so Fisher
captured with the Rook instead but here
uh just played Knight captures on D5 and
he was now in this position on move 20
that Bobby Fischer resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here so
of course these seven score is now
covered there's no defense against uh
Queen to h a Checkmate if you capture
then the row covers the two squares then
again it's Checkmate and if you don't
capture uh your queen is hanging so okay
you could stop checkmate with a move
like G6 the bishop covers h8 but now
just Knight captures on B6 Jordana Queen
and there's no playing this you can you
have some compensation but it's not
nearly enough let's say captures now
even Rook captures on E6 is happening
and after I have captures captures on G6
attacks the bishop attacks the Knight so
there's there's no playing this bishop
capture Sunday for Queen characters you
basically have uh you have nothing here
like you have nothing uh so yeah after
Knight captures on D5 I don't know 20
Bobby Fisher resigned and uh Max over
took the lead in their match and the
second game ended by uh Bobby drawing
the game and Max said in his book that
he he remembers this encounter very well
and as Bobby was already a very
well-known player uh don't be fooled by
me saying that Bobby was only 14 years
old here he was an absolute beast at the
age of 14 and uh if you remember already
at the the age of 13 he played his
Immortal game against Mr burned the game
of the century and uh after that game I
mean even prior to that game people knew
who Bobby Fischer was but after the game
every person in the world of course knew
who Bobby Fischer was so here he was
already 14 quite then quite a strong
player but okay you could argue that
even though Mr burn was a was a very
strong player he was no former world
champion like Max zube who I mean
contested Alexander Allegan for the
title he he defeated all classical chess
20 times I mean that's um I mean that
that that's a very impressive so that's
who who uh 14 year old Fisher was facing
here but still an absolute crushing
defeat for Bobby and he was not happy
with this but like I said this is a two
video mini Saga uh Bobby will have a
chance for rematch three years after
this game was played in Leipzig in the
uh just Olympiad so stay tuned for that
and we'll see if Bobby got his revenge
or did Max uh uh you know uh continued
his lead or even maybe improved it uh so
yeah that's the game I hope you guys
enjoyed it I even have a photo of this
encounter let me just uh
uh load it up and there you have it so
it's a bit small uh but yeah this is uh
basically the photo of the encounter
there you can see Fisher playing uh with
some uh people you know watching
watching the games and uh this is the
game that we've just seen as you can see
it has the white pieces or maybe it's
not maybe it's just a game that they
were analyzing and then someone took a
photo yeah it's it's hard to say it's
not like they they took 50 photos they
probably took this one and that's it uh
but yeah fish are wearing his uh famous
colorful sweater there and uh as one
would expect you know wearing a suit
much like everyone else here uh but yeah
yeah that's it for this one uh crushing
defeat for Bobby Fischer uh quite a nice
miniature for you guys to enjoy and
share with your friends at the bar in
the library uh if you uh often play
something like this it's not a line that
um you know it is impossible for happen
I mean these are all very very standard
moves this is a pretty standard attack
and already here it's very hard for
Fisher to play I mean but after a queen
to B6 is just Deadlock last year I mean
absolutely absolutely crushing uh so
yeah once once again hope you guys
enjoyed it I would like to thank Kim
Tori Jensen Orlando's Danielson uh GM
Thomas rusman and Michael Kennedy and
vladislava satenko for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
with part two of this mini Saga it will
be Fisher with the white pieces against
the former world champion Max in the
Leipsic Olympic of 1960. uh I hope you
enjoyed it I will see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your day